[Music]
well good evening at welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight George W Bush spent the
first nine years of his retirement
saying almost nothing in public and good
for him
it's a dignified and restrained posture
that is long standing tradition among
former chief executives but nobody's
staying silent in 2018 so President Bush
is now speaking out and he has a cause
seeking amnesty for millions of illegal
immigrants that his administration
allowed into this country the context
for his latest remarks was a speech that
butch was giving in the United Arab
Emirates that's an authoritarian Islamic
Petro State alongside him as he spoke
was Michael Milken the convicted felon
and financier during his remarks the
former president said he wants immediate
amnesty for daca recipients quote
America's their home he said Congress
has got to get it fixed
Bush explained that we must give
citizenship to illegal immigrants as a
reward for providing low-wage labor to
companies who don't feel like paying
American wages quote there are people
willing to do jobs that Americans won't
do the former president said we ought to
say thank you and welcome them well this
is the magical world of our elites
people who've never had to worry about
how illegal immigrants might affect
their kids schools or the crime rate in
their gated neighborhoods or the social
cohesion of their communities because
they're insulated from all of that
instead they repeat diversity is our
strength three times like a spell and
assume the best will happen the rest of
us is the former president noted can
shut up and say thank you so how exactly
is this faith-based immigration policy
working out so far well let's see we
watch dreamers blockade Disneyland we
watched them harass lawmakers outside
their homes to demand an amnesty that
they have no legal right to that's
ominous enough but there are other signs
here's one Linda Sarsour
she's a professional activist she's the
child of Palestinian immigrants you
would think that she'd be grateful for
the opportunities this country has given
her family especially considering where
they came from but know Linda Sarsour
is not grateful she hates our country
and the people who founded it during a
demonstration yesterday in Washington
star Seward denounced America and then
went on to attack Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer
for the color of his skin watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
notice the cheers from the crowd a lot
of people agree with Linda Sarsour and
that should make you nervous we've
invited millions and millions of people
into this country in recent years there
are now more immigrants in America right
now that at any time in the history of
the country is America more United than
ever before is it stronger please it's
just the opposite and everyone knows it
maybe that's because our elites welcomed
immigrants by telling them how horrible
America is and how bigoted its native
population our immigrants believe that
why wouldn't they
it's not their fault it's ours we're
creating a lot of Linda's our source
this is a recipe for Civil War diverse
countries need a reason to stick
together they don't do it organically
our elites ought to be staying up late
night after night every night trying to
figure out what that reason is why
should we hang together a shared
language a shared culture a shared set
of core beliefs pick one our ruling
class rejects all of those just shut up
and say thank you that's their answer it
won't end well Ivan Sanchez is a
Democratic congressional candidate in
Texas for the seventh District there and
he joins us tonight mr. Sanchez thanks
going up thank you so much mr. Tucker
for allowing us to practice democracy
and allowing the other side of the aisle
to say a few words Oh amen we do every
night and I believe in that with total
sincerity I want to hear us American
dream thank you but maybe we'll agree on
this tell me your response when you hear
a child of immigrants say to a room full
of people here illegally immigrants this
was founded on the extermination of
indigenous peoples does that bother you
well I believe we're we're a country of
immigrants right everyone from all over
the world came here and are still coming
here but we did an a sense forces
ourselves in to create now the greatest
country that the world has ever seen but
I guess um what we're not I'm not an
immigrant you're probably not an
immigrant we're not all immigrants but
there are a lot of immigrants you're I
agree and I think a lot of them oh you
are ok great well I think a lot of
immigrants are good people actually but
I think it's really important that they
become part of this country and in order
to do that you have to love the country
does it bother you when someone that
immigrants listen to like Linda Sarsour
says this is a bad country run by
racists and its history is inherently
racist it's this country's built on
murdering people do you believe that I
think they're just a little bit
frustrating about the lack of
representation much in Congress or
legislators my friend I am basically a
dreamer with papers I was brought to
this country at six years old through
absolutely no fault of my own my mother
was actually a prosecuting attorney and
my father a geophysicist in the country
of Colombia and there were my father was
kept at my mother's mom's office was
blown up and so a letter came to my
mother's office saying next time you put
your kids in the school bus they're not
coming back
so we landed here I was sold on the idea
that we were coming to see the great
Disneyland and Bill Clinton and we had
to start all over but I don't know why
because it's just familiar it's a
familiar and a great story and I'm I'm
in favor of that story but I just want
to get but the details matter to me I'm
an American citizen I suppose like you
do you think you said they don't have
representation do you think people who
aren't citizens deserve representation
in Congress I think they're humans and
everybody reserves the respect and
dignity most definitely I have no idea
well that's that that wasn't I'm Sojin
really pay do they do people at waylynn
do people who are not American citizens
deserve to be represented in the
Congress of the United States you
suggested they may service this clear
sorry deserve a voice they deserve a
voice I think even if why would they
deserve a voice Reagan even even if I'm
not asking weighing in Ronald Reagan
here I'm ok hold on I'm just asking you
so people who are not American citizens
deserve to be heard in the Congress does
that include people living in Namibia or
Norway or Iceland I mean does the world
deserve a voice in Congress our
understanding that the Americans are
saying was Congress is for American
citizens that's what our people yes yeah
the people that are definitely
contributing to our society and live in
our neighborhoods definitely do deserve
a voice and you know if if we go so
citizenship doesn't matter you don't
need to be a citizen to be represented
by the Congress no no of course you do
but there's people that have been living
here for longer times than I have and
pay taxes and take their kids to school
and contribute to society and look I'm
not I'm not attacking him it's just sit
if you're gonna have a country you've
got to figure out what it means that me
over one country in the world that's
what we want to do this country provided
us opportunity how beautiful is that we
want to make sure that this country will
progress we want to stay the number one
in the world right and there's Charlie I
believe that and that's why and I yeah
I'm not gonna let you give your speech
because I probably agree with a lot I
want to remain number one too that's why
I want to ask you these two questions
before we as Americans let people become
citizens and vote in our elections and
get represented in that Congress should
we ask them to agree with what's in the
Constitution and speak English yeah the
thing is that the last immigration
policy we had is older than the internet
or computers is very outdated
if you want to legally immigrated from
Mexico or foreign India so we're almost
at time so I'm gonna try I'm really
gonna press you I haven't hold on I want
to pressure to answer my question which
is should we ask that immigrants before
they become citizens speak English well
and agree with the Constitution I I
agree that they need to learn the
language like I have right
and of course follow the law but at
times just like like my mother right she
came here to United States all of a
sudden a lot of people cannot wait 25
years to immigrate so they're like we
don't want to know it's not really up to
here is it up to your families under
yeah it's they can't if their family's
life is endangered would you wait oh but
but people's lives are in danger around
the world and I feel sorry for them but
why does that mean they have a right to
live in my country well this is the
country was found on immigration and no
it wasn't I mean let's have it was it
was founded as a haven for the rest of
the world whatever the poem says that's
not true so but I'm just saying where
did they get that right why do they have
a right to move here if their lives are
in danger
well we we're the most caring world a
nation in the world right we have asylum
in this that's one of the ways that I
came and this is not about even the
daily reporting these people would hurt
our economy significantly I mean all
these reporting these the dreamers are
we will spend hours outside that look
that's a whole nother debate tonight and
I don't know if you're prepared forever
but I mean thanks a lot for coming on I
appreciate it thank you thank you for
having me